hello everyone and welcome to another
very important game from the penultimate
round of the 2019 isle of man chess
tournament it's Fabiano Caruana versus
David Antony Haro
and we said that we were going to show
one more game at least and then talk
about the standings a little bit and who
will get the spot in the candidates
tournament so let's dive straight into
it Fabiana with the white pieces opens
with Seif that's not a seed that's
woodsy for the English opening with E 5
and Knight to c3 the reversed Sicilian
variation of the English Knight to c6
Knight to f3 and the g6 Anton prepares
that finger to the dark square Bishop
wave d4 it captures Knight captures and
Bishop to g7 now attacking the knight
twice Knight captures in c6 d captures
and sees because he's expecting d5 sorry
not B D captures and c6 was played and
here we have a Queen trade Queen capture
scheme characters and the Bishop to g5
with check with King Teti 8 and now
karana just castles Queen side already
threatening mate in one with rook to d8
mate so Bishop to e6 now the rope covers
the d8 square and E 4 and this position
has been reached a few times and the
mostly played move was nice to have sex
but here Anton has a brush up to h6 and
it seems this is a new move he prepared
as it is already as a move 10th we have
a completely new game he offers a trade
of Darkspore bishops and you don't
really have a choice of declining this
you could play something like h4 but
then after f6 you would again have to
trade so here Fabi just raised with a
bunch of characters Knight captures and
the Bishop to e2 and ok Kim to e7
connecting rooks now comes at b3
strengthening the pawn here so you can
shift this bishop over to f3 with f6 and
now comes
h4 knife to it an IQ of 7 or E
maneuvering the knight back into the
game and now f4 taking away these two
squares from the Black Knight with h5 by
black and now Bishop to f3 with a 5 by
black not allowing any future expansion
with with something like this and now
comes Luke HD 1
with Bishop to g4 now wants to trade the
dark square bishop as well with Bishop
captures H captures and now g3 and here
rook a to the 8th so here G Haro pretty
much has everything nicely nicely done
he if he trades the pair of rooks then
nothing should be a problem here
Bobby trades the one pair of rooks with
rook captures King captures now he wants
to keep the rook here on the h8 file a
square for the time being sort of as
Reaper Carson so if for the rook to h1
comes the white cannot push h5 and break
through so rook back to h1 now still not
allowing this roof to move and now King
back to East 7 and King to d2 fabi
starts to bring his King into the game
we have beast sex by black and now
Knight the d1 the idea is nice the e3 or
f2 and go after the g4 pawn with a for
creating weaknesses on the Queen side
also he wants to play a capture say
captors and maybe arre maneuver this
rook over to a8 so he can infiltrate
white position we've nice 2 f2 by Fabi
going after the g4 pawn and now a
capture Sun b3 with a cap for some b3
and now you're G for pawn is under
attack the problem with f5 is of course
the wife will not capture white will go
rook to e1 now threatening to capture
with Czech and after the King moves he 5
check creates a passport for Fabi so not
something he hard wants to allow he goes
rook to e8 he gives up the g4 pawn but
he will grab some points on the Queen
side with h5 first by Fabi there's no
rush to capture on g4 rook the a2 with
check and now King to e3 we have G
captures an age 5 and finally rook
captures on h5 rook the be to going
after the b3 pawn and now Knight
captures on g4 with Brooke actress and
b3 with Trek King to f2 and now look the
B to check King to f1 and here G hair
goes for a series of checks rook to be
one check King to e2 rook the be to
check for because back king of three
ropes to b3 check King to g2 and after
roof to be to check
Bobby Flay scheme to h3 saying that he's
very much
interested in playing out to the same
game as his pieces are a bit more active
and well Johar has a CC point so it it
is a little advantage for white rook the
b1 now threatening rook to h1 with check
so rook to f5 going after the f6 pawn as
both the knight and the rook attack it
so G Hara take this opportunity to make
a double attack against the rook and the
pawn Knight to d6 with rook captures on
f6 and now Knight captures on e4 with an
attack on the rook and rook back to g6
we looked the h1 check King goes back to
g2 and the now rook the c1 going again
after the c4 pawn and here Miharu goes
for tonight
to c5 sorry first nice to e5 from Fabi
we've looked the c2 check King to h3 and
now see 5 so the the c6 pawn is no
longer a target and now King the g4 Fabi
makes his way into the position with the
king and here Knight to d6 going after
the c4 pawn as it is now attack twice so
what can you do here is white I feel
free to pause the video and try to
continue this game with white well I
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations on being such a such a
great end game player and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
it's f5 this is what Fabi played and now
already you can see that f6 is already
covered f7 is covered and it's gonna be
it's gonna get very complicated here
Miharu captures the pawn with Knight
captures on c4 and now first rook the
ECX check as the night covers this
course the King has to go back King to
d8 and now we have Knight captures in c4
rook captures on c4 and King to g5 so
here
Fabi decided to sacrifice a pawn so he's
now down upon in a row component game
but his past point is is a really fast
pawn so let's see what happens rook the
c3 first attacking the g3 pawn Fabi
pushes it forward we have g4 and now c4
so of course it's going to be a race
King to f6 now comes route
g3 again attacking the g4 pawn and now
g5 as the C file is now cleared for
Black Sea pawn we have c3 Fabi continues
g6 and now how do you continue you don't
really do gain anything by c2 if c2 just
rook the c6 year never going to Queen
this pawn you can go back with the road
because just rook captures another
interesting idea is c5 now rook the c6
doesn't really do anything but you have
rook to eat oh and this pawn will not
cross the sea to square so you have to
start pushing the other pawn as well and
now let's say King f7 be for king f7
wasn't really that great of a move but
I'm just showing this line just to see
how complicated it is to mess up King to
g7 was the way to go but King to f7 is
extremely interesting because of g7 b 3
and now rook to e8 check for example
King to c7 now comes look the e7 check
and here it's basically a draw you will
not be able to do anything more here the
problem for black is that if you go back
to any of these squares or let's say
King to b6 then you allow this check and
then the rook just blocks the pawn rook
captures you'll get pawn captures or
King captures just really it does really
matter c2 and now you get a queen the
game black also gets the Queen into the
game but now Queen captures and b3 with
check and this point is much much faster
than the then the C pawn although with
with correct play it also should be a
draw so geek ro
starts pushing the other pawn instead of
c5 and instead of C 2 with b5 g 7 by
Fabi and now b4 and here came to f7 now
guarding the queening square with the
king and here the problem with c2
although i mean you you do want to start
pushing your pawns is rook to g6 again
just a blocking so the rook will not be
able to sacrifice itself and after rook
characters and pawn captures c1 Queen
you're getting a queen with check and
now after King to d7 you're gonna go
Queen e8 check King to d6 Queen e6 check
and after king c5 you're gonna play
Queen e5 check and I centralizing move
and
TRUCKING moves and now you push g7 and
you are getting your second Queen much
faster than black can do anything so we
have a different move McGee Haro goes
for rook captures and g7 with check he
can't allow the G pawn to Queen King
captures and now C - of course recurring
to the Queen the pawn and now rook the
c6 wouldn't wouldn't really work if room
to c6 you get b3 f6 and now King to d7
attacking the rook f7 King captures and
c6 f8 Queen and but now you also get c1
Queen and now black is just up two
points so here Fabi went looked the e1
guarding the queening square sideways
and now b3 with f6 by Fabi b2 quite a
race this is turning out to be f7 and
now c1 Queen and now the problem for
Genaro is that of course fab will not
capture Fabi first brings the Queen into
the game while still having a look on
the board King to d7 and now once again
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the quickest way to victory for
white while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations and
finding the quickest way for whites to
win and for those of you who just want
to enjoy so if you try something like
Queen Queen here check Queen here check
then you allow the blacking to start
running down the board but with Queen to
f5 check it's a bit different this is
what Fabi played and it was in this
position that the Davi Don Tony Hara
decided to resign the game as you don't
really have any more moves it's
basically a mating for after the King
moves we have worked a six check King b7
and Queen to b5 check and now whatever
you play you're just getting made it if
you go here then this is mate if you got
something like this or this then yeah
just rook to a6 is made so whatever you
do it's after Queen to a5 its mate in
three so yeah Aggie Haro resigned here
and with this victory
Fabiano karana takes so lead in the
tournament and here we are now going to
show the standings after 10 rounds so
these are the standings now and we have
to discuss the standings a little bit
because it's just really crazy Fabiano
so lead with seven and a half out of ten
then with seven points we have seven
players one cow kiddo
like Senko magnus carlsen 11 aragon
nikita big of Hikaru Nakamura and David
Howell and since Corwin and Carson are
basically not competing for forces of
spot in the candidates of course the
Carson is not playing in the Candace and
Fabiano
gets automatically into the candidates
for being the previous Rogers
championship challenger so it's
basically between the between six of
them so who are we going to see in the
candidates phone call Alex Sink Oh 11
are and Nikita way to go Hikaru Nakamura
and David how how played a beautiful
game yesterday against against Gary
shook and ended up on seven out of ten I
like everyone else it's gonna be it's
gonna be well it's gonna be hardest for
I believe 11 and and for Hikaru because
11 faces Magnus and Hikaru faces fabiana
Corwin so here karana and Magnus have an
opportunity to you know the kind of
block 11 and the HiPower from from the
candidates if they just play a solid
game don't allow them to go for a win
but then again you know I don't think
something like that that they're
interested in doing something like that
but both of them have the white pieces
Hikaru has white against karana and 11
has white against Magnus so I believe
they will try everything to get to get a
win in today's game and get their spot
in the in the candidates so it's gonna
be really awesome but it'd be awesome to
see every one of these players in the in
the candidates tournament David Howell
in particular I think it would just be
an awesome opportunity for him so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Ramakrishna Malibu
Nia and the Glen Cove check off for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video Sarah
thank y'all for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the isle of
man chess tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and well whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day